welcome to c-span book TV's afterwards
program my name is Christopher Hitchens
and I'm here in the for me on a custom
role of interviewer and producer of my
friend and colleague George Patton who's
produced two volumes of the essays and
George Orwell appropriately picked and
introduced and commented upon
and so today or well as our subject so I
I wish we had more than an hour you I'm
guessing that you will have read DJ
Taylor's book on George Orwell I haven't
oh what a shame
it doesn't matter because what I wanted
to say from his some book was something
that I have a feeling you'll agree with
Taylor writes at one point says when I
read other people writing about George
Orwell I keep thinking hey this is my
author you're talking yeah do you ever
get that feeling um I do and it we all
have a you know you and I and a few
other people we know and some we don't
know are part of a really fanatical
group of Orwell lovers and it's very
personal and I started reading more well
maybe a little late it was in my early
20s but it was at a critical moment when
I needed a kind of a model I needed to
know how does one become a writer and so
I just read straight through what was
then the only collection of Orwell's
essays in journalism the four volumes uh
collected essays journalism and letters
and just read straight through it was
like reading a autobiography and the
audio so being personally addressed I
felt very close to the voice of those
pieces and I think those are where you
get closest to Orwell
to his voice to what's essential to his
really what in his character is strong
and worth emulating and I became a
slavish emulator and imitator for a
while in my 20s I think it's a good way
to learn how to write just to find a
writer you feel some affinity for and
just master their prose style their
rhythms you get get the
the the cadences into your own nerve
system and and then try to find your own
way into it but that's the closeness
Orwell produces in people like me and
you and so yeah we feel a little bit
proprietary when we read other people
right writing about them to it but not
when those people get him right and I
think your book why Orwell Matters gets
him right you said in that book Orwell
got the three basic questions of the
20th century right imperialism fascism
and communism and that's that sums up
his political and literary achievement
as well as any single if I was feel they
derived from each other in other words
from what he saw about imperialism
especially this sort of sexual
repression and racism that it involved I
think he found it quite easy to decode
the appeal of fascism and the danger it
is it was some extension extension of
imperialist not purely but to a good
deal yeah a to a good deal in many ways
that was the case and then because it's
funny he hardly writes anything about
fascism he seems to just assume everyone
will know that it's evil and needs to be
fought against that's what was nothing
strange there was no analysis of it um
he takes it for granted that it's
completely unacceptable but it's in the
course of fighting against one kind of
church at Arianism that he discovers
that there are many people came into me
as allies who are not yes and actually
the visit was a an almost equally
dangerous illusion taking place on the
other side of the murals that's right
and he turned the same withering
scrutiny on his own side that he had
turned in on a much easier target Nazi
Germany fascist Italy Franco's Spain and
that was when he made most of his
enemies on the left and all the way to
the end of his life yeah now I realize I
haven't said quite enough about you
I should process some of this at the
beginning but those of you don't know
him already or knows work mr. packer
well first came to my attention actually
as a novelist writing from Africa run
facts and black oh well who is capable
of fiction variably as
the essay the long essay formed by which
I would kill now pari reaching a large
audience mr. Packers were especially
from Iraq in other parts of the world
but especially from Iraq in The New
Yorker has got him a great deal of
attention and I believe you now have a
collection of essays we were in out you
a new book out called interesting times
writings from a turbulent decade but
back to fiction you probably over
praised me there I did write two novels
they were read by about 35 people and
although I learned a lot from writing
them I did not learn to be a novelist I
don't think Orwell wrote a batch of
novels in the 1930s that were in the
tradition of anglo-american realism and
I love them I don't know how you feel
about them but for me keep the
aspidistra flying is just a marvelous
book Burmese days is the one that really
lasts the longest but you just don't
feel that Orwell's working in his most
natural grain in those novels you feel
the essayist sort of pushing through the
yeah the the illusion of fiction all the
time he has something to say he has an
argument to make he has something a
proposition about the world all the time
and he doesn't have the restraint and
patience of a natural fiction writer and
that's why we can be grateful that he
once wrote in I think did why I write
that if he been left to his own devices
he would have been a kind of 19th
century British novelist like his heroes
Dickens and Gissing but events and the
turbulence of the 30s and 40s pushed him
into becoming what he called a kind of
pamphlets be here yeah um and and by the
way I should have to introduce it's one
of the very few completely unconvincing
things and again mostly I was just going
to say that because really it was not
events to push him in that direction it
was his own inclination um
his also it's a very rare case of it
being too conceited in other words he
said if it wasn't for all these polemics
I have to write I could have been
Charles Dickens we'll come on yeah
that's a pretty much um the Burmese say
the same Burma that he flattered them by
writing three novels about
Bernie's days yeah Animal Farm an
imaginary phone right I actually heard
that line in Burma last year when I went
through oh yes Orwell is still a huge
presence in Burma all the more I think
now there's a young generation who did
not learn English well growing up they
came after the generation that was
schooled by the British they've been
they've had their futures utterly
blighted by the totalitarian regime
there and Orwell speaks to them not just
because he wrote about Burma but as you
say because he wrote about totalitarians
of 1984 has so many echoes in Burma
today and so you can actually find
Animal Farm being sold discreetly in
book stalls on the streets of Rangoon
and so he's a kind of he's reached a
hero to these younger Burmese writers
after being condemned for his supposed
imperialism by the the hunter and while
we're on contemporary to tell China's in
which we might as well stay with a bit
I've been in North Korea and you know
when one goes as a reporter when hopes
to avoid cliches so I thought I'm going
to try not to mention 1984 because
everyone says it's an Orwellian stage
and funny use of the word of worrying
yeah but in fact the great thing about
totalitarianism is that it is a cliche
it seems to do the same thing over and
over again
Kim il-sung founded North Korean state
the same year that that 984 came out
ranked and it's as if someone gave him
the novel in Korean and said you think
we could make this work and he thinks
well a general will sure give it our
best shot
it's it's absolutely remarkable it--
imitated art yes it's the same when
people in countries like this come
across so well as the North Koreans one
day we'll they're amazed I think the
greatest compliment perhaps ever paid to
one writer by another in the 20th
century was by Cheswick me wash when he
in the capture of mind when he wrote
about the situation in Stalinist Poland
he said there is a book in circulation
it's called 1984 words you can only get
it privately it's circulated with great
secrecy and fear among the other party
and he said I personally was very
surprised as we all were to find out
he'd never visited the
Union because how could he get our
texture how could you get the texture of
it also right without having had this
experience I've remembered
Nigeria for is about the circulation of
an illegal book within the inner party
in my other Fingal's D so it's it's
extraordinary that is a great question
how did Orwell know he lived almost his
entire life in England he travelled a
bit through Europe at the end of World
War two he had his years in Burma but
other than that he was very parochial he
was confined to the island and and yet
he wrote in his essay on Arthur Kessler
that the British writers of his
generation had failed to understand
totalitarianism because they had not
lived the way Kessler Salone a Camus and
other continental writers had and so he
was sort of criticizing the you know
what he called the parlor Bolsheviks
Auden spender etc for not feeling what
it is to live under that kind of regime
Orwell felt it but he had the same other
than his years in Burma and his
suffering and hard times in the 30s
which they did not have he had the same
education and then lived in the same
England that they did and yet he did
feel it and that's a it's a bit of a
mystery how he could have known it so
well well I think I have a possible M
and also slight correction to you in
reverse order then or correction first
not as insidious all that of what he did
spend a lot of time in the Far East
admittedly as a colonial policeman but I
think being a colonial cop gave him an
insight into the master servant yep
indeed almost master/slave relationship
is very useful in describing some of the
again dirty secret sexual underlay of
totalitarianism then he was in Spain and
he was in Barcelona at a time when the
Communist Party did briefly takeover and
there was a police terror and third very
important he noticed that all the truth
about Spain had been written out of the
record and he C wrote in looking back on
the Spanish War he was really afraid
this was becoming a habit now in Europe
that if the leader says something never
happened then it never did and you can
see the germ of 1984 done partly by the
father of your old nation colleague
Claud Coburn father of Alexander yes
and by not just by communists I mean
quite a lot of other people fell for the
line that the the Communist Party was
the best defender of the Spanish
Republic and it's only very recently
that the archives of with Franco's
system and the Stalinist system have
been open and we do know what happened
in those may days in Barcelona and
actually what all said was happening was
in every detail true yeah he refused the
lie he would nd a second point I want to
make is about going on with his
insularity is his first a real book is
written in French Karen out in Paterson
and was originally French book he spoke
very good friend she spoke at least to
an Indian and Brandi's language it
wasn't written in French he wrote the
essays in it the sketches in English he
wrote a couple of little essays for a
small French publication called the pro
Gracie week here act when he was in
Paris and shooting along I see on
colonialism and that's right that's
right and then wrote the manuscript of
down-and-out which he which was rejected
by TS Eliot and some of the other major
Genet rejection passed no it was
rejected by um yeah I think it was Eliot
he was at Faber
in 1931 or 32 and and rejected and then
rejected animal farm yes many years
later
ah so Ian or will had as did German
action Harcourt brace in America one of
the best rejection letters I think ever
written every aspiring writer should
have interjection that it pasted in
their hat to consult it says Jim is true
well thank you for letting us look at
your manuscript now more farm we
unfortunately it's impossible to sell
stories about animals in the United
States yes right in the say in the
country of Disney they could make such a
factual small now they really thought it
was a story about the phone and then
Animal Farm became a very good cartoon
film so it is they were wrong about that
tuition bug suing yeah but just to get
back to the experience of reading or
well and and the essays in this book um
when I started reading him and I don't
know if you had this experience I didn't
know much about fascism or communism or
imperialism I was looking more for an
example of how a writer
carried himself in the world and how to
transform experience into sentences and
how to do it in a way that didn't call
more attention to the self than to the
experience and you in again and why I
write Orwell wrote good prose is like a
windowpane another may be dubious claim
but helpful in the sense that his words
are always pointing to the thing and not
back to the the self and they reveal so
much about a character I mean there's
something almost you feel you know him
when you read his essays you feel you
know how he speaks you can hear his
voice you know his irritations you know
how he's going to react if you say
something is almost alive with you even
though there's also a certain remoteness
to Orwell
he doesn't let you in on everything in
his life he doesn't talk about his
marriage very much in his writing he
doesn't talk about his child Richard or
well he doesn't talk about his parents
some of the basic things that American
memoirists make you know gold out of
that are the subjects of book after book
for or well we're kind of off limits he
was a bit constrained maybe by late
Victorian shibboleths that way but
nonetheless you had this very strong
sense of the person behind the words and
that was what first drew me to him and
makes those essays you know worth
reading over and over again I should
press on this by now it's um just for
those of you watching us this is
George's first term selection it's
called to all artists propaganda and
it's about Orwell's essays and then
another one called facing unpleasant
facts which is his more political stuff
we might say I've comment on both the
titles but yeah when all world writes
about himself he says well when I
God started all I knew I had was little
literary ability and a power of facing
unpleasant facts I'm everything a power
of facing very good I want you to call
my book that for a while um it's all
something almost biblical about it yeah
it's an unusual phrase isn't it a power
of facing as if it it's an active force
it gives you some advantage which is
true he was able to look at things at
times almost exaggerated the ugliness or
the bad smells I seem to seek them out
with a kind of relish but nonetheless
things in himself in England in
democracy in literature in the working
class and in the working class which the
famous line from his great book about
coal mining and coal miners the road to
we can peer the working-class is smell
you know which Orwell said isn't
necessarily true but it's what middle
and upper-class people think and it's
the reason why the the the class divide
is such a hard thing to overcome in
Britain because it's almost physical
it's not just a kind of mental snobbery
and I think that line my right that that
line will really bothered Victor
Gallants who yeah sure of the Communists
went on for the rest of his life saying
this is what all we'll thinks about the
working-class yeah exactly
they smell him with it but he doesn't
romanticism um the workers that he's on
their side um he doesn't remind us that
as in this hall nor does he remembers
the colonial subjects on whose side he
also that's very as it often finds them
repulsive absolutely the opening lines
of shooting an elephant which to me is
almost that it's the perfect Orwell
essay where you just see his mastery of
the form at its best and I use it to
teach the essay a lot because if
students just see how he does it so
clearly but in the at the beginning he
says with one part of my mind I hated
British imperialism with another part I
thought the greatest pleasure would be
to stab my bayonet into a Buddhist
priests guts and that's a kind of
confession about himself and about the
Burmese that may be painful personally
but as we from a literary point of view
it's very powerful because it invites
the reader and says I have all sorts of
conflicting feelings and I'm going to
own up to them and even make them the
subject of this essay another thing you
mentioned his reticence yeah that what
about what she never says anything he
never tells us why he resigned from the
Burmese police that's right
but I guess it's that he was afraid if
he carried on with it he would become a
sadist he had a streak of that in him
you know um
he wrote once that to understand fascism
you have to have a streak of fascism he
was talking about Jack London whose book
the iron heel was a kind of prophecy of
fascism but he might as well have been
talking about himself too and that too I
think is it is an answer to that
question we were talking about earlier
how could Orwell have understood what
was happening
behind the the veil of terror of
Stalinist Russia Nazi Germany without
direct personal experience of it except
as you pointed out in in Barcelona and I
think it's partly because he he had the
sterner stuff in him though she's
British will you break up you say in
your video introduction that most of his
arguments were with himself I thought
that was very well encapsulated because
a lot of people are if you like
naturally liberals or naturally
progressives they think it's just you
know a nice way to be and he might dab
so you didn't think like that at all had
scorn for those who who did I think he
what's fascinating is someone educating
himself out of an upbringing where he'd
been taught to looked down on and rather
fear the lower orders to look on colored
people in the Empire as a raw material
to be very suspicious of Jews just
clearly took him a long time to get all
the time that's the reason his way out
that's right your book makes that clear
sorry excuse me could carried away with
my own velocity and then one very very
enduring prejudice which he doesn't cure
himself all this
absolute hatred and disgust for
homosexuality that's right
he used that phrase the pansy left to
talk about Auden and spender and yeah it
was not the nicest side of him and their
women who think that he was a terrible
misogynist and even that his misogyny
his inability to create convincing
female characters for example Julia in
1984 is not the the most persuasive part
of that novel but that that was part of
why he ended with such a dark vision of
the world this is the subject of a book
by I think her name is Daphne Pitt
either or weird-ass TKE I don't think
it's right I think that's giving
totalitarianism not enough credit for
being the the darkness that was
surrounding Europe at the end of war
Welles life but it's true that um it has
a strange attitude you might almost say
toward individuals unlike a journalist
today he doesn't spend a lot of time on
characters in his nonfiction you you
never get to know any coal miner that's
true by name you don't get to know
anyone in his outfit in the militia in
in Barcelona particularly well you learn
a few of their names sometimes he just
recites them almost like an honor-roll
but you don't get to it to the inside of
there being nobody does the perf about
the soldier he meets yeah and so feels
at comradeship with the first country
with the Italian militia managed our
Salone yeah and that's a beautiful
moment at the beginning of homage to
Catalonia and then at the end of the
poem that can that concludes that essay
looking back on the Spanish war and that
but he also says I didn't want to meet
him again because if I did it would ruin
my first impression which is that this
is sort of the flower of the European
working class and that I think is the
way his mind always goes away from the
individual and toward the social type
toward the the political and social
significance of digging coal underground
also entry surface
distance you see him he has one point he
replies to someone who asks him if you'd
like to come to dinner and meet Stephen
spender then a famous poet of the Pierre
addendum and he says no because I think
I may want to write about him and I find
it much harder and I think what I'm
going to say it II disagree
I've only much harder to do that once
I've met someone that's her sort of both
very human and also very inhuman saying
I don't so trust myself to be in to
mention because he knows that as he says
he wrote in the essay and Gandhi being
human means attaching yourself to other
human beings and being willing to be
broken down and even destroyed by your
love for this individual he was that
essay is quite harsh about Gandhi's
impersonal love for all of humanity and
his cruelty or neglect of his own family
for Orwell this was a perverse inversion
of the proper order of things which is
you love the individual not mankind he
was not a saint he was not a lover of
mankind in that sort of Gandhian way
although he's been sanctified by some
people posthumously so it's absolutely
true that that's where his feelings
drive him but there's also a counter
force that that cuts him off from those
attachments and I think it may partly be
simply because they get in the way of
writing and writing honestly and so the
individuals are missing strangely
serious by the way is a good
illustration of another point you make
which is Boyle's ability to start with a
very arresting opening sentence and that
one on Gandhi as I know you know begins
we're saying what all Saints should be
considered guilty until proven innocent
we could just swap Orwell openers here
no
the autobiography should be trusted
unless it reveals something disgraceful
which is the beginning of his essay on
dolly in will main and lower burner I
was hated by large numbers of people the
only time in my life I've been important
enough for this to happen to me yes
shooting and Ellsbury yes but I think
with the Gandhi intro as well it shows
something else which is his general
distaste for the spiritual he was the Oh
something shady or creepy about that and
his general
contempt for religion there we had a
respect for it too I mean he obviously
knows the Bible very well he quotes it a
lot clearly from memory almost always
WordPerfect well as as good as that's
how I know it's from memory hasn't yeah
there's a key moments his marriage to
Aileen no Shaughnessy he insisted on
having it done in the Church of England
ceremony he was buried in the Church of
England graveyard
he liked the liturgy you feel it's a
kind of cultural attachment to the the
words the cadences and the traditions of
the Church of England which has
absolutely nothing to do with heaven
which he describes somewhere as in the
vulgar versions seeming like a choir
practice in a jeweler shop so yeah he he
was not a religious man there's no sign
anywhere of a belief in in the afterlife
but I think he had a strong feeling for
the Protestant revolution however I mean
it shows in his attachment to Milton
who's the great bard of that but his
favorite line was a line of Milton's
which was by the known rules of ancient
Liberty in other words that there is a
human instinct for freedom and he writes
about the Protestant centuries as he
puts it in a positive way contributed
the European enlightenment and I think
in back to 1984 again the struggle
against an alien language that's been
imposed upon people that of Newspeak and
the struggle to find out what is in the
secret book that they'll either party
has right is a very good analogy to the
struggle of Wickliffe and with um
Coverdale and Tyndale to have the Bible
translated into English which they were
all market and the English revolution
was important I think there's an essay
called the Prevention of literature
which is about the effective of not just
totalitarian countries but it the
internal censorship that came with the
the totalitarian ization
of British intellectuals and that essay
begins as the effect on literature the
effect on books he says son you know
books like some wild animals can't breed
in captivity
it kills the imagination and that essay
begins with a sort of a scene from a
gathering of pen the writers
organization that were well attended
it's an unusual case in which he
actually places himself at a some sort
of public meeting as an example off
point for the essay and at this pen
meeting no one is able to stand up and
defend free expression everyone is
defending the right of the Soviet Union
to do this or it reminds me kind of the
worst of sort of identity politics when
it invaded writers organizations in this
country in the 80s and 90s suddenly the
last thing anyone wants to speak up for
is free expression I think a good
example which is very near to your heart
is when Salman Rushdie came under the
fatwa from the Iranian government and it
was hardly any writer who was able to
say this is an absolute atrocity except
you did
oh that's too kind to me I mean there
were lot of people who did very well
member Susan Sontag actually convened a
very good nation actually of I think you
were among the very first but well but
back to or well that essay then
continues to imagine what if Milton were
to come back today and attend this pen
meeting he'd be astonished and no one at
the meeting in nineteen forty five or
six was able to defend free expression
with the unqualified force of Milton
three hundred years earlier so I think
you're absolutely right that that period
was a kind of a touchstone for him in
the in the struggle for to the title of
your line other morning we say all ours
propaganda I have a question to ask you
I know that he wrote that in wartime she
wrote in 1941 in wartime all writing is
now propaganda it's in an attack I think
on Alex comfort and his pacifism and
that is right that's right where does
this come yes it he says it's in several
places he says it for example in his
essay on Dickens and does he does he
does but what he means by it and he says
it also I full said begins very
brilliantly Dickens is one of those
authors is well worth stealing there you
go I knew we could have a little
ping-pong game of
opening liners no it's fun um he I think
he might say it in another essay called
a meaning of a poem for him it means and
the reason I gave the book this title
not that all art it could have been
written by you know the minister of
propaganda Joseph Goebbels or even the
Ministry of Information in wartime
England but that all art implicitly has
a point of view it has something to say
about the world and as he says it's
trying to push ah one's view in a
certain direction it has a persuasive
function it has a uh if it's worth
anything it has a kind of a world view
that it is advocating and I think it's
not a resignation to the crudeness of
wartime propaganda it's more his sort of
smoking out the art for art's sake crowd
who would like to have art be a separate
from the world of ideas and politics and
events and he's saying especially in a
time like his the 40s yes it was
impossible to be a serious artist and
not have something to say about events
even if you're writing very internal he
makes that confession for himself and
says every line I've ever written in the
last twenty years were they were very on
a serious topic or any serious line his
written with hope of forwarding the
course of journal clerics action in
democratic socialism is the phrase uses
and against totalitarianism I mean not
every writer is going to be as
explicitly political as Orwell nor nor
do we want them to be but I think it's
his technique as a literary critic and
as a critic of a field he practically
invented which is popular cultural
criticism to find the implied or hidden
worldview in what seems to be a kind of
benign or not particularly pointed realm
of art or culture like the postcards of
sort of donald mcgill postcards that are
sort of semi pornographic or at least
mildly risque that were sold in England
at that time
monotonous ly indecent eat not that's a
great phrase for it or the boys weeklies
or the detective novels in his essay
raffles and Miss blandish he's always
that essay is a good example what are
you going to do with an essay that
basically compares a two different eras
in British detective fiction raffles
from the turn of the century and a novel
called no orchids for Miss blandish
which apparently was rather popular
around 1943 and the point he comes to is
there's a shift in moral point of view
between these two raffles has a code
which is not a particularly lovable code
it's the code of a hypocritical English
gentleman but nonetheless it's a code
and so there's certain things that can't
be done whereas no orchids for Miss
blandish the only code is power and the
pursuit of it and that's what should be
admired and the great passage in that
essay where he says people appreciate
power at the level at which they can
understand it and he has a boy and in
Glasgow slum worships Jack Dempsey a
student at a Business College worships
Lord somebody or other a reader of the
New Statesman worships Stalin it's a
difference in intellectual level but not
in moral outlook and that's how he finds
sort of the I'd say the moral
implications of something that seems as
trivial as detective fiction I'm so glad
you bring this up because it brings me
quicker than I wanted to but that's to
acknowledge or something I wanted to
raise a lot of his writing about ethical
codes and reticence and discretion zone
versus ruthlessness and the cult of
violence reflect hostility to the United
States yeah say that look at the comics
the British boys read look at the
American ones that are coming into the
full sadism and gangsterism and exactly
so we we began by saying well you began
by saying of my book that I said he got
three great questions of the 20th
century rise yeah but I add that he got
on one of them I think not totally wrong
but the importance of America here was
something that he didn't write enough
about when he did it was rather sketchy
and all the condescension you have a
chapter on poor well in America which he
never visited
he loves some American writers Mark
Twain Moshe
Jack London Henry Miller oddly enough
but I think for Orwell America was pain
Thomas Paine absolutely British born but
I think for Orwell America was it didn't
have the things that he was attached to
and that are the things Winston Smith in
1984 is clinging to for sanity the the
odd traditions the things passed on from
one generation to another like the
lyrics of of a nursery rhyme or a song
old books that and bookstores that trade
in old books of course some of these
things are available here he wouldn't
have moved little country churches with
brass rubbings you got it
the the yew tree in the country church
yard for while those things were sort of
the bulwark against the monolithic
paving over of everything by not just
totalitarianism but by modern life I
mean he hated concrete he hated central
heating he hated most mechanical
entertainment he hated advertising and
all these things seemed to be coming not
just from the east in the Soviet Union
but from the West in the United States
and and his in this sense there was
something parochial about he did dislike
country Americanism yes that's right was
then beginning to become a disease on
the left because I think he understood
it to be a kind of anti liberalism and a
refuge of of a particular kind of
snobbery that you find on the left which
sees America as the vulgar ization of
all good things that it's connected I
think to the that plus conservative
version cowboy ISM yes but you're I
think the point you made in your book
and you're making
was absolutely right he didn't see
America as a guarantor of the things
that he cared most about it culturally
especially it was an alien and
distasteful place to him it's a pity
that he died when he did because his
friends at partisan review knowing he
was unwell TB I'm trying to get him to
come to us firstly for treatment really
ideal because structure might seems easy
to get yeah I'm very hard to get but he
died but poppy in fact I don't know as
Dickensian death yeah and they said come
over and you'll like it
and it would have been a great addition
to the partisan review crap and he at
one point he contemplated making a
voyage down the Mississippi which makes
it nice to have well going on since 1884
his next book would have been about the
Mississippi now yeah I've got something
for you on the American this is very
suggestive slight but I think you might
like it you will have no difficulty in
telling me what the opening sentence of
1984 is the clocks were striking
thirteen it was a bribe as a bright cold
day in April and the clock was running
thirteen yeah that's right
I was reading John Adams daily day and
he was writing about how to get the
colonies together and how to coordinate
a revolution against British power and
he says it'll be very difficult to get
all thirteen clocks to strike at the
same time and there you go and then at
the end of the book in the dictionary of
Newspeak at the end of March 84 they
have he shows how the attempt is made to
obliterate all the possibility even
thinking about freedom from the language
and just to make it impossible even to
formulate the thought and he gives an
example of a sentence that couldn't be
translated into new speak and it is yeah
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that's created and the following music
you know you know there is this possible
one certainly possible to and certainly
one implied compliments to America and
that but just imagine Orwell traveling
through early 50s America know the
America of a Lolita the America of the
Eisenhower years when the
suburbanization
of the country was happening the highway
system was in play was being put in
place intellectuals were beginning to
leave part
in review leave Greenwich Village and
take some comfort and and security in
universities it I it's it's almost
unimaginable it's like a whole different
era had begun by that time in Orwell to
me belong so completely to a previous
era that was harder more exacting is it
more austere yeah and and and all the
the abundance and comfort of of post-war
America would have think would have left
him pretty cool although you're right he
would have found places to love I think
the Mississippi is one maybe the West
with its affluent I would've thought New
York - I totally not San Francisco he
did love London I mean he lived in
London and he worked in London he even
made a point of staying in London during
the Blitz when other people were leaving
there but once London was no longer at
risk it's uh its charms for him wore off
which tells you something about the way
in which he actually pursued hard
experience actively rather than simply
not avoiding it and so instead he moved
to one of the hardest places in the
British Isles the Isle of Jura off the
coast of Scotland where he lived his
last years probably hastened his death
in 1984 but this I don't know if you saw
this his son Richard or well his adopted
son had kind of maintained his silence
for 60 years and we only knew he existed
we didn't know anything about him and he
gave an interview about a year ago he's
I think an agricultural engineer
somewhere in English news which is kind
of what you'd expect and he describes
being Orwell's son in those years in
Jura and far from being this gloomy
apocalyptic you know Jeremiah of
totalitarianism Orwell was just a lot of
fun he took him fishing he took him
boating they went on all these
adventures they nearly got killed a
bunch of times it wasn't physically easy
but or what was completely attuned to
the natural world and to his son and
shared his love of of physical things
and of nature with Richard and it's for
me gives me a lot of pleasure to know
that or what was it was a good father if
I'm not supposing the rulebook
first he had had a very bleak childhood
himself obviously didn't like his father
yeah when he mentions the analogy of a
family for bridge Society it has every
figure in it except a daddy which is a
kind of strange omission right a family
with the wrong people in charge that he
mentions maintenance and distant cousins
in which bono they're no fun that's
right
second though it's very rare have find a
joke in Georgia oh well that when they
do occur they're quite funny they're
very dry um I'm trying to think of one
well in Animal Farm when the when the
animals take over one of the things they
do is go into the smokehouse and take
out the hams and give them a decent
burial I thought it was quite funny yeah
and his essay on confessions of a book
reviewer is extremely funny yes yeah the
picture but generally pretty bleak um
how do you come out on the question of
Lionel trilling who says of all that the
great thing about him is he's not a
genius he is I think extraordinary thing
is how someone so relatively ordinary
could just by refusing to lie and
working very hard and not caring whether
he lost a job or or his or Ellen got his
book published oarsmen was able to
change in the 20th century in other
words qualities of character alone are
sufficient to become a great writer and
to become one of the most important
writers of the century yes and no part
of what drew me to Orwell back in my 20s
was this sense that this is available
this is not the mad brilliance of Saul
Bellow this is not Faulkner's you know
arabesques this is not this isn't even
Hemingway's you know highly
self-conscious stylized prose this is it
felt like natural prose I mean that is a
conceit because that's not it doesn't
make you feel as you do when you're
reading a book Oh for example why do I
bother why do i it's impossible I can
admire but I also you know can feel sort
of discouraged by know with Orwell you
feel encouraged by it you want to go do
it yourself that's the feeling that that
he gives me you want to try to write an
essay like that you because the prose is
simple it has that that the plain style
and it and it seems like the leading
characteristic of it is honesty which
one ought to be capable of on the other
hand I think trilling might go a little
too far in just in the sense that
decency alone that's that I think the
word he uses about me well is not it's a
key or well word common decency and it's
important one but Orwell was an
eccentric Orwell was a difficult man he
had his incredible full of
contradictions he was not so simple and
good I think as trilling would have you
think and you alluded earlier to some of
his antipathies and his he was a man of
violent dislikes and in some of his
earlier work before I think he calmed
down with a certain amount of
self-assurance denunciation was his
characteristic mode yeah so he's not so
he's certainly not a saint and he's just
he's not simply a good man
whose qualities of character allowed him
to write great books but those but
there's enough truth to that that he is
sort of a model available to everyone
especially when she's writing is very
difficult to measure him being afraid
say yeah exactly or if he was afraid
whether physically or morally he then
would have noted it and forced himself
to overcome it power face yeah exactly
well we've only got about ten more
minutes and what I thought I would do is
take up the idea of Dickens being a
writer worth stealing seeing the world
call him and talk about attempts to
appropriate oh well yeah the other
meaning of Orwellian it's not usually
used to describe a totalitarian state is
in some sense someone who stands for a
certain set of principles that's the
news I like it the positive use of it
and he's often invoked I mean he was
very he was invoked against his will
somewhat in the early days of the Cold
War the only ones he saw by people who
thought that Animal Farm initiated for
was specifically attacks on socialism
which he he didn't want
that's right and he had to actually
write a statement saying I'm a supporter
of the Labour Party and in sauk is not
an indictment of English socialism it's
a warning about the tendency of all
modern political thought to move toward
yeah
talent is it by the way he added and he
was very firm to the English it was to
show that the English were no better
than Abel that's right that's right
um well the best way we could take this
on the chin you and I since different
times we both viewed with favour the
removal of Saddam Hussein from power
yeah
and I think a well was in our minds but
different times and certainly I know of
other people who will try is it worth
asking do you think what would all well
another one but just to finish the
little history you started
he was also claimed by Norman Podhoretz
of commentary a Shanda in an essay
called if Orwell had lived basically for
we live here he would have been a neocon
he would have been Norman Podhoretz
well on that I can't pronounce because
put on it's thought that well would have
taken the American side in Indochina and
I think I could be certain that that's
not so but because of his anti-imperial
because he was very strongly actually
colonial especially in that part of Asia
which he knew so you know yeah and he
actually mentions when he's in Paris at
the end of the war the revival of us of
left opposition type anti-stalinist
paper and one of the great essays that
it's printed which is about the attempt
to restore French colonialism in
Indochina yeah which is the ancestor of
the American and exactly he would have
regarded it also seen it as a colonial
war as a bad news for that reason he
would have been I think you're absurd in
Iraq is different because it was not a
colonial war you know there's in a way
there it's very hard to say and it's a
little dangerous to claim but we can
speculate because because we have to
there's two different arguments to be
made about that one is that or what
would have seen in Saddam's rule other
than perhaps North Korea the nearest
thing
to the world he imagined in 1984 I mean
you say that totalitarianism is a cliche
Iraq is a great example Saddam was big
brother he had big brothers mustache his
face was on posters all over Baghdad it
was on television all the time you could
not escape the eye of Saddam's many
secret police Iraqis used to say they
thought he knew what they were dreaming
exactly and and that he was inside them
and that even after he was overthrown
they felt they they continued to suffer
from the effects of death when we were
in action and was the pornographic
government apart we never been more
horrible I mean Saddam's son was sort of
the human incarnation of the pornography
of totalitarianism with rape and all
kinds of crimes so that that one is easy
to say that or what would have seen that
regime as it was it would have been no
defenses of sovereignty or state
sovereignty or
of you know that this somehow was an
anti-islamic war that this is an anti
Arab or he would have seen that regime
as a modern secular totalitarian regime
which is what it was on the other hand I
would say not so secular it's the damn
Hussaini poised Allahu Akbar on the
Iraqi flag and yeah you know for the end
he you landed in Sunni Islam for his
purposes that's right the other side of
it is the language used by the Bush
administration both before the war and
after the invasion which in many ways
was mendacious was euphemistic was
misleading was bad language it was the
kind of bad language that allows bad
political thought which is the subject
of politics and the English language may
be the best known of Orwell's essays and
I think oral would have been merciless
in stripping away the rhetoric of George
Bush Dick Cheney Don Rumsfeld
and Karl Rove for that matter and so
which Orwell would have
had his fun the vote though the anti
totalitarian or well who would have seen
Iraq exactly as it was and known that to
stand up against Saddam was to stand up
for the Kurds to stand up for masses of
Iraqis who did not want to continue this
way and he would have understood
something that one learned upon going to
Iraq which the many most Iraqis were
relieved to have that regime undefeated
let's not forget yeah exactly that's
been forgotten on the other side the or
well who hated political lying and and
and political of a gun and propaganda
exactly so hard to say well I didn't see
yeah what uh it's it's also hard because
you never really wrote anything much
about the Middle East and hadn't been he
was very skeptical about the foundation
of the State of Israel which was the big
argument going on in the closing years
of his life he wasn't very drawn by the
promises ioan ISM and you sympathetic to
the Arabs of Palestine do you think he
believed that democracy and and the
freedoms that you know that Milton I
stood for could take root in non-western
countries is there evidence that he
lived in the universality of I'm not
quite sure of it I mean this was
actually one thing we really have been a
couple of minutes I'm sorry but by way
of illustration he writes to his friend
his Indian friend milk Raj Anand Dhoni
died a couple of years ago yeah um
budding novelist and essayist and who
gets attacked in India for writing in
English using the conquerors language
and gets mocked in England for being a
sort of white Indian or I'm sure or two
nationalists in ship and all says don't
worry about this you're bound to get
both those things but I'll tell you what
I think one day there will be the will
being the Department of English
literature as a special subset of it
written by Indians in English and of
course now you can't go into a decent
bookstore I've seen five or six
brilliant Indian or Pakistani writers
writing in English writing so much
very often better than English people
yeah and so Naipaul would have been kind
of the following in the line
what rifles from Trinidad reviews Indian
but I mean I was think people literally
from soca so none obviously honey fleshy
Arundhati Roy says he comes age so
certainly there's the he was he was not
a little Englander in his view of
culture and his view of expression but
one pernicious idea that's resulted from
the disaster Ron George I'm not a great
master of ceremonies this organic why it
was a real conversation I wouldn't be
saying yeah you'll have to condense this
in less than a minute I'll do that is
gonna the last word is that people who
don't look like us can't do this and
that's a terrible mistake and I don't
think war would have fallen into that
trap of imagining that freedom is only
for for white people which is would you
wrote messages